but first more terrible polls for Joe
Biden more Panic from his fellow
Democrats who are now begging him to
retire if the 2024 race were held today
Donald Trump would beat Joe Biden in a
hypothetical matchup according to a new
CBS poll he'd even beat uh Kamala Harris
by more but Trump even gets to that
all-important 50 threshold Biden
meanwhile is more unpopular than ever
look at this number 72 percent think
that Biden is not physically healthy
enough to be president he's not only 34
percent believe that Biden could
actually finish a second term before
resigning or dying Joe Biden himself
doesn't even seem to think he'll outlive
his son's legal woes according to NBC
News is what they said quote the
president is even lamented aloud that he
might be dead before his son's case is
resolved now Biden's allies are now
reportedly worried that Hunter's
indictment will now strain the
president's 2024 Focus what Focus others
in Biden's orbit they are terrified
about the impeachment inquiry along with
the underlying corruption allegations
you have famed Democratic strategist
James Carville he's continuing to sound
the alarm over Joe's ability to win
re-election Peggy Noonan
enthusiastically endorsed Joe Biden 2020
now says Biden's re-election bid is a
historic mistake but tonight this isn't
just about the bidens and Joe's age and
Corruption concerns put simply Joe Biden
has been an awful president by every
single measure whoever is calling the
shots over at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
is doing a historically god-awful job
every major problem facing this country
has gotten dramatically worse because of
Biden policies Biden can't even get an
endorsement from the United Auto Workers
Union they're now striking after years
of green energy regulations that are
wreaking havoc on U.S automakers forcing
electric vehicles on a country that
doesn't want them and on workers that
are going to lose their job and
meanwhile inflation that continues to
rise after a year of historic increases
homelessness crime spiking especially in
blue cities and blue states the border
worse than ever it was just named the
deadliest border region on Earth and as
we speak thousands of illegal immigrants
mostly single men by the way abusing the
Asylum system Crossing into the U.S
every single day our very own bill
malusion just witnessed one of the
largest mass Crossings in the history of
this country over 2200 individuals
crossed into Eagles pass in Texas just a
few hours that's all it took keep in
mind the illegals are now coming from
all over the world that includes China
the Middle East Africa Latin America
according to Homeland Security audit 76
percent of all illegal immigrants take
it into custody are merely just released
into the continental U.S by the Biden
Administration by the way no background
check the world is also more dangerous
and far less prosperous under Joe Biden
it's not just the disaster in
Afghanistan the unchecked hostility from
China and Russia now the Mallows in Iran
they have access thanks to Joey's gift
of Ransom six billion dollars to spend
on terrorism and weapons and the nuclear
program or whatever the hell they want
to spend it on that of course the
generous gift from Joe Biden in the form
of a ransom payment from five U.S
hostages I thought we didn't pay ransom
for hostages and on top of it he's
forcing other countries to also give
them money then of course we have the
anti-semitic anti-American United
Nations they're alive and well all over
New York City this week probably happy
about the payment so expect a pretty
warm warm reception for Biden's speech
that will take place at the U.N tomorrow
along with several days of horrible
traffic in New York City you the
American people you pay billions and
billions and billions of dollars a year
for for the privilege of Hosting this
pointless traffic jam that's known as
the United Nations we should get out of
the wef the who the Paris climate
Accords and frankly uh you know look at
all the countries look at the head of
Iran is coming here the head of all
these hostile regimes coming here just
about every other Global organization
hates our Great American way of life but
of course they're more than happy to
cash our checks you pay the bulk of
monies for the U.N that has historically
been anti-us and anti-semitic maybe it's
time for the U.S to now Boot the U.N
into the East River or how about this
let's let China host the United Nations
they can pay the billions they can fund
all these you know green projects that
they're pushing on the world while the
U.S is wasting your money also if the
U.N is really so deeply concerned with
all this climate change and all these
human rights well they should probably
relocate closer to some of the source of
their problems again the People's
Republic China would be a great choice
unfortunately the U.N is here to stay
under Biden he he values the global
Community far more than we the American
people this is America last on steroids
tomorrow he'll speak to the U.N for the
third time as president but he has never
managed to visit East Palestine Ohio you
know he just can't seem to find the time
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else